everybody welcome to live coding with
Jessie I'm Jessie and today we're gonna
work on the react native web app that we
started to a couple weeks ago I don't
remember when we started it let me know
what the stream quality is like last
time we had really good quality but the
time before that it was terrible so
hoping we have good quality again and
YouTube's telling me that the quality is
okay so I hope that's the case
all right cool so it looks like it's
looking good
hey everybody in the chat all right so
I'm gonna go ahead and get started
and then I'll go back to the chat if
you've never joined in before this is
how it works I will do Pomodoro sessions
so let me get a Pomodoro timer running
let's go
it's just fun here we go tomato timer
will work so I'm gonna start this
Pomodoro timer it's 25 minutes well 25
minutes is up I'm gonna stop coding and
I'm gonna answer some questions hey
we're gonna try to get through to
Pomodoro cycles see how that goes
and then at the end of both Pomodoro
cycles if there are any questions left
I'll answer those and if it starts to go
really long I will have to cut it off
and so I may not be able to answer all
the questions depending on how many
questions we have because I'll have to
go to my normal day job as a software
engineer all right so let's check out
what we have so far here's the actual
app so this is as far as we got last
time we just have a an input
and a title on the page but the cool
thing was we did all this in react
native and it's showing up in like Dom
primitives basically so these are divs
right so that's that's the idea behind
react native web you can write it react
native and render it as a web app and
you'd be able to render it not only as a
web app but since it's in react native
you can render that same code you can I
don't know if renders the right word
when we talk about mobile but basically
that same code could be used to make an
iOS app and an Android app and
potentially other things as well so
let's go to the code all right hopefully
that's all big enough for you the only
thing is blocked out by my face right
now is just the the terminal that that
actually is running the local server so
not really anything there that would be
useful to see to give ourselves a little
bit more space for code all right so you
can see our package JSON at this point
is very very basic
we have react react Dom and react native
web react native web includes react
native so that's why we don't actually
have react native here in our our main
dependencies this package JSON will grow
as we continue and eventually if we'd
like to turn this into a mobile app as
well so it it'll get a lot more complex
but right now it's it's pretty simple
and we only really have one component
and that's a pas and it's also very very
basic okay so this will get broken out
into separate components but for now I'd
like to just work on building out the UI
a little bit
and we this is gonna be a game like
basically a math game so I used to play
this math game with with my oldest son
when he was just learning basic math and
I think we demoed it last week but the
the whole idea is you have to get math
problems correct to win the game right
so we want to build out a basic UI I'm
not gonna worry about graphics at this
point so we're probably just going to
use like colored is to represent the
characters in the game for right now and
then later on I'm not really a graphics
person so stuff to figure out what I'm
gonna use for the characters but we just
need to get something on the screen
visually so that we can test out the
logic all right so for right now the the
input is there that's that's what we
need let's get some I guess let me
explain first what I what I'm thinking
at first it's just a basic thing so let
me make this bigger all right so this
will probably just be at the top as our
title we're gonna Center this on the
page the input all right so above the
input there'll be a math problem right
just for now it'll just be a simple
addition problem you type your answer in
here and you hit submit right that's
basic but then above that or even on the
sides depending on the screen size we'll
have the hero character on one side and
the enemies on the other side right and
if you get the math problem right an
enemy will disappear if you get it wrong
an enemy will appear right so the way to
win the game is to get so many questions
right consecutively so that all the
enemies disappear right so that's the
very basic idea
one simple the simplest version of this
game and then we could think about
adding in some more complex things later
maybe like having high scores being able
to save your your data things like that
but for today I'd like to just get that
basic UI built out and I see so there's
some action in the chat so hey everybody
that's is joining us if you're if you
didn't catch the the beginning and
you're wondering why I'm not checking
the chat just hang in there I have a
timer going when that timer goes off I'm
gonna check the the chat and answer all
your questions
all right so in react native we don't
have the concept of divs or spans or you
know P tags and things like that we have
these other primitives which are based
the very basic is the view and the text
all right so we're gonna be using mostly
views here
so this main view is going to stay our
route view right but then we're also
gonna make let's let's call this our
loops actually I wrote div again so you
see that okay so this view is gonna be
our here of you feel for now we're just
gonna give it like a class basically a
style of hero
later on we'll probably break these out
into their own components but it's a lot
easier to work with them in one place
when we're starting out so we're gonna
say style hero and that's all we're
gonna have in that view oops you
and this one is gonna be enemy okay so
for now since I know there's we're gonna
start out with multiple enemies I'm
gonna make three okay
we're obviously not gonna keep copy and
pasting these you know but for now we're
just gonna kind of hard code a demo of
the layout so down here where we have
our styles and react natives so react
native comes with this this style sheet
dot create and you can put styles in
there basically the styles are a
JavaScript object so instead of normal
CSS you have these camelcase versions of
CSS not all of CSS is available here so
it's it's a subset of what you would
normally use on it on a website so it'll
your your app probably won't break but
you'll get a little error in the console
letting you know if you're using
something that's not supported by react
native so for now we're gonna add so
this is an object object syntax so we're
gonna add a comma and then we're gonna
add our hero okay and let's just give
them a height a width and a height and
in react native the units are just plain
numbers right so we don't say pixels or
e/m or whatever it's just just flat-out
a number right so for now let's keep
things small let's just say 40 and
height 40 okay so we're gonna keep them
at this point just squares right just
really basic and then let's give it a
color so
so we're gonna say background-color
and i don't really know i x-value for
off the top of my head I'm just gonna
put in I wonder if you know I've never
tried this but I wonder if I could say
just like blue I know you can do this on
the web but I don't know if you do it
react native so I'd like to know if you
can do it so I'm just gonna try it
alright so I just copied and pasted
whoops there we go I just copied and
pasted here oh and we're gonna call this
enemy and let's just say red for the
enemy and let's save that see what we
get
hey here we go so it actually works
although I don't know about you but to
me this blue looks purple maybe just
because it's up against the red it's
like messing with my eyes here but
anyway so here's our hero and here's our
three enemies great so I definitely
learn something that you can just put
the names of colors in there so that's
useful especially when we're trying to
just mock things up really quickly
alright so the positioning is in issue
right now like we just put them on the
page but they're not at all where we
want them to be so let's try to get them
positioned properly so first thing we
can do is move them down below the title
and let's add our usual I'm thinking
probably should add a container for our
hero in a container for our enemies so
let's do that now so basically our we're
gonna have a view and styles that I'm
gonna say container for now because I
suspect that these containers are gonna
be very similar so that we'll just have
this container class and oops
we don't want itself close that we want
to actually close this view around the
hero and then we're gonna have another
container around all of these and you
know I don't have whoops there we go I
don't have like my auto there we go the
auto format wasn't working us worried
for a second I never had that setup okay
so now we have containers around here we
haven't given the containers any styles
though yet so let's let's do that right
now everything inside the route is
getting this justified content a line
item center let's let's take the route
and make its Heights I think we can do
we can do percentage let's see if this
will work
and we need to put that all right so
we're gonna try height 100% on that
route I'm not sure if it'll work or not
I can't even really tell no it no it
didn't work so Oh actually you know what
we should do
let's go with like one is this it let me
see there's some property on flex that
will make it take up the entire the
entire container no that's not it
I may have to look that up now so our
actual this is ID root but that's not
really our root let's just mess around
in dev tools for a minute to try to get
this right so this should have our flex
yeah our flex grow of one let's see what
this one does so it's not something and
our even our body is doing this to
nation of us on this - mm-hmm
let's just look this up I had to look
this up for a project that I'm working
on now but it was like two months ago
and I've already forgotten so let's say
full height you react native there we go
as possible make view a hundred percent
and react native yep this looks good all
right so flex one is suggested here
which we tried take up the full screen
position absolute lose to if it doesn't
sell your problem okay so we can go with
this position absolute we could also try
to get the dimensions first and then set
that as width and height okay
okay it looks like they're doing the
flex one thing yeah I think let's just
try this position:absolute them probably
the quickest to test alright so I
apologize if somebody already put this
in the Hat chat let me see each element
inside Flex container if you put flex
one for each of them will give all the
same with height if it's flush your
column okay so John Hanson was talking
about the Flex as well let's shred this
and I don't want for need these alright
let's see what this gives us
yay alright this is is the full the full
height now right and okay great
all right so now we know we have a full
full height and width view and then
within this view let's all right we're
at the containers let's sell the
containers get sidetracked there we have
container and within the containers see
how we want to do this
I think the normal flex will work for
these containers because flex direction
is column by default and so I believe
that's what we want
so in react native flex direction by
default is column okay but here's what
we want to do so let's take this route
and say the chef flex direction row and
[Music]
actually let's comment this out for now
really could do this in dev tools okay
so this is like what I mean by flex
direction so by default on the web so if
using regular react this is would be the
layout if you set if you're using
flexbox
by default on react native in react
native the Flex Direction is column
which would have been like the first
view that we saw all right so we're
going to within our views probably
switch back and forth to get the layout
that we want that so
we're gonna probably like basically
we're gonna nest views with different
flexbox properties to do our layout
right so we're using flex flex blocks
because that's what what the layout
stuff is for react like built-in to
react native alright so we're gonna need
a a wrapper around this alright so we
want to leave our main route as just
flex Direction column but then we'll
need a wrapper around this to set these
two flex direction row so these line up
like this we're gonna space them out but
for now like we this is a better lineup
okay let me check my time in about five
minutes I'm gonna go to the questions
the chat and answer some questions okay
so let's add yeah let's add this another
view the views are going to start to get
crazy
it'll get simplified once we split these
out into separate components though
alright so this view we're gonna set the
style of and we're gonna say this is a
battlefield alright so this is going to
contain our our battlefield right where
our hero and our enemies do their their
math battling and this will encompass
both of our containers for our heroes
and enemies now we can go down here
for a battlefield we can grab this flex
direction ro will remove it here and
then just add it in down here and let's
see if that gives us what we want don't
like that space oops we forgot a comma
let's check it out now okay great so
that that does give us what you want so
the main layout remains flex column
right flex Direction column but then
within this see if we can get get the
outline here of this div so within this
container we switch to flex Direction
row and then once we're outside of that
container we're back to the normal
normal layout again okay so not bad now
of course we want to separate these
these warring parties here and well
that's while we have this open let's
just add some styling right here so we
can get immediate feedback so okay so
the Flex one here on this element is
gonna give us it's gonna spread us out
vertically but what we really want yes
here is so this gives us hmm
let's even give it a whiff there we go
okay so we're gonna give this container
this is our battlefield container we're
gonna give it a width of 100% we're
gonna stretch out the the battle here
now I don't really want this to take up
the full width of the screen for now I'm
gonna add some padding on this one it
might not be a bad idea just to add
padding on the root but we can change
that if we need to later so I'm gonna
say actually let's just we'll add the
padding in on in here because it's a
little bit different for react native at
least we have a different option so our
battlefield with is gonna be 100% and
then we're gonna say padding we're gonna
say padding horizontal right and then we
can give it a padding so I'm gonna say
16 see how that looks
okay so here we have sixteen year and I
think I've forgot to add in I'd add it
in flex one yet so a flex one when I
added flex one here alright so this is
basically what it's doing it's making
this first one this first container for
our hero the full-width with the
exception of the tiny bit of space that
we give to our enemies so this this will
actually achieve what we want for right
now so I'll leave it but we may want to
switch that up at some point because
it's logically like it may end up being
confusing for us because we'll expect
there to be kind of like an even
battlefield in terms of our containers
actually let's see what happens if I do
this oops didn't want that
alright this this actually will work out
better
it doesn't look better right now but it
will in a minute let's add flex one to
both of these containers so we do get
that middle that split down the middle
you know so basically each one would be
50% verify that yep this is what we have
now what we can do in these containers
as well is say like how we want the
elements inside to be displayed so flex
say flex direction and then we have some
some options right so oops that's not
what I want
is it just fat content all right so it's
not justify content and then it'll be a
line items there we go so if you're
trying to like Center something
vertically or horizontally it's always
either going to be justified content or
line items I can never keep straight
which one is which so I always just try
both so this will give us you know where
we want them to be for now I think
Center is perfectly fine so let's add
our align items
Center oops forget I put that all right
so we're gonna add our line item Center
and then that should Center both of them
there we go so now we have our little
battlefield right
now also like we we do have an issue
with spacing right and we ought to
justify our content as well so we get
that vertical align
we're gonna Center that too so now you
see our heroes centered our enemies are
also centered we want to give some space
between our enemies and there's there's
two ways we could you try to do this we
could set this container to be larger in
terms of vertical height and then whoops
my timer went off alright sorry about
that
alright let's pause that for a second
and let me go to the the chat and answer
some questions all right
okay so Philip says Philip dares me to
code a program which makes a new random
language I know it's possible I try it
and it works alright that's that's
pretty interesting I don't know I'm not
sure how I know about that but that's a
good idea for a future project
thank you rob says good morning social
stock says good morning alright so a lot
of people are saying good morning so I'm
just going to say good morning to
everyone thanks for watching
Surendra asked if I can explain the
Python language I my experience in
Python is very limited so I I'm not the
person to explain that all right if
anybody else watching is really good
with Python maybe in the chat you could
try to explain a bit the only thing I
really would say about Python is the
syntax is based on a lot on indentation
so that's that's kind of all I remember
from the brief time I spent learning
Python
let's see caval asked about my IDE my
code editor and it is Visual Studio code
John Hanson says should the input type
be text or number it's probably gonna it
should be number so I don't remember
what I have in there now I probably just
copied and pasted it from somewhere the
last time
okay look at there are some questions
here that I think I actually just
answered as I was going along so I'm
gonna skip some of those
let's see someone which I can't
pronounce her name because it's in
different characters as what about
flutter flutter is really interesting
and it would be a different way to
create mobile apps I don't know that you
can create a web app with flutter so
flutter seems really interesting I just
I don't know enough about it to do a
stream on it yet but I've I've read a
little about it and it it seems pretty
cool
okay
we had a question about whether this
will be uploaded to the channel later
yes all our live streams get
automatically uploaded to the channel
later on adjust my monitor here it's
easier for me to read okay
state a question what are we trying to
make in the webpage so I explained a
little bit earlier but just very briefly
we're gonna make a math game where the
user will have to answer basic math
problems in order to defeat the the
enemy Sebastian says I enjoy watching
you on my 5-minute break at school I'm
glad that you enjoy it
I'll have another question do you use
PHP so PHP I I have used it in the past
I don't currently use it for my job so
my PHP knowledge is really basic though
so I've done just some like file
uploading yeah I've made like a basic
file uploader for PHP and then all the
other PHP I've done it's like WordPress
plugins so definitely not a PHP expert
you know by any means and hey I can't
believe I made it through all the
questions I think I did I made it
through all the questions in the five
minutes so let's let's start another
timer
I may have to finish up a little early
but for now this should be good I'm
gonna check the stream quality really
quick all right it looks good quality
looks good awesome if anybody has any
issues with the stream quality let me
know I just see a question how long will
the stream go the streams probably gonna
end in about a half an hour so another
half hour you could always catch the the
rest of it in the recording if you if
you want to alright so let's go back to
our app and let me kind of continue on
with what I was explaining I gotta
change the song I'm listening to it's
kind of
I can't focus in this song
okay all right so we have to option if I
have more than two but to my mind there
are two options I'm thinking of here we
can make this container bigger right so
the the goal here is to space these divs
out because this is three divs right we
can make this container like larger
vertically then we could use flexbox to
space these out evenly within that
container or we could just add a little
bit of padding or I'm sorry margins to
each one of these the easier thing to do
right now I think is just to add the
margins so I wonder actually no what I
have a different idea maybe for the UI
we would want to like let's say push
this down a bit so yeah I think this
would be better let's set a standard
height for this container what I'm
thinking is like at some point when we
start adding and taking away enemies
it's gonna cause this input to jump up
and down right because it's position
based on the height of this container
above it so it'll be a nice it'll look
nicer if this doesn't jump up and down
when the enemies do it so let's take
these containers and give them some sort
of height one if we could do it these
ones or maybe maybe in this container
yeah let's do it on this container let's
try it right now and see if we can go
I think we tried this already let's try
it I'm gonna try it again
there we go I guess I didn't try it so
basically what i'm doing here is flex
one and we're bumping this down this
looks weird now but we'll get down to
here and and fix this up a little bit so
if we have flex one here now when we go
down to this we can say justify content
space around we could do space between
we could do space evenly right space
evenly looks the best to me so we're
gonna go to space evenly okay so we need
to make two changes back here so on our
battlefield
we're gonna go flex one and then on our
containers we're gonna change justify
content from center to space evenly and
I will give a shout-out to John Hanson
because he was mentioning this further
up in the chat and I skipped over it
because I knew I was just gonna do it
here but John you were like a hundred
percent on the right track there with
this so now we have our battlefield with
our enemies spaced evenly our heroes
over here so this is looking more like
bit like what I have in my mind and with
what the original game looked like the
original game was really basic it's on
my github page if you want to check it
out it's one of my very first repos but
the original page the original game was
just built with jQuery so it was in my
early days of coding so now we have this
let's add in we need an actual math
problem so we're just going to hard code
one end just to see how it'll look in
the UI so the math problem will be here
or yeah for now we'll put it here us
actually it might not be
if we put it in the middle of the
battlefield that might be cool too but
let's keep it here for now and then this
input definitely doesn't need to be this
big if they're just gonna put in a
number it's probably gonna be like two
or three digits so we can adjust that
and then put some space in here at the
bottom so we're not right up against the
the bottom of the window and all right
so let's put in or let's see if you
let's put in a container div so let's
say
let's call it math container I don't
want to waste too much time thinking
about names so that'll do for now all
right so we're gonna put wrap our button
our input and then our math problem
which we're gonna about to put in now
we're going to wrap that in in that
container and then we're gonna have this
text so like in react native I could
never just type text outside of the
container so I couldn't just have text
here right that would throw an error it
has to be inside this this text so let's
put
so we're gonna just let two plus two for
now okay that'll be got to be good
enough I guess
hey border gray border with okay so I'm
not giving any style to this
maybe I should let's say math text
alright so we'll do some basic styles
here for math container
we'll definitely want this to be I guess
we just give it some some padding for
now and really we just want vertical
padding right so we're gonna do padding
vertical and let's say 16 as well just
like we did with our other container so
we're going to give this some vertical
padding and then here we're gonna give
our math text oops
math text let's just say font size and
let's make the font size on 20 maybe see
how that looks and that should be okay
for now just to give us an idea okay so
we have our little padding here and we
have our math problem we could if our
math problems are gonna be like this we
definitely have space to put our input
up here
that might not be a bad idea I'd like to
see that let me know what you think
right - just take a look at it like this
and then we'll we'll see what its gonna
be like when we switch the input to be
in line here and then we'll see which
one we like better
so though the way we're gonna do this is
we're gonna have a container just around
here and we'll set the Flex Direction to
Rho and then that should give us what we
want here and we'll keep the submit
button below and we'll style that that
kind of as our next step so we need
another view let's say there's a bath
container let's say bro we'll call it a
throw since it's going to be in a row
have flex direction row that's one a
little piece of advice that I have is is
never spend more than a couple seconds
trying to name something because it's so
easy to change the name later on and you
may actually completely get rid of that
view or whatever you're working on it
might have different functionality later
it might there's so many reasons why
that name could change it's it's a waste
of time trying to figure out what to
name it so the first thing that pops in
your head just just use that like I I
spent too much time like wasting time on
naming things and seen it happen with
other people it's it's definitely not
not worth it so we have this math row
and we're gonna put
a flex direction of row on a math row
and it's not forget the comma and let's
see what that does for us hopefully what
I thought it would
hey there it is okay so that works it
doesn't look great right now but yeah
you know I think I'll keep it like this
for now I want to make this smaller
definitely add some padding here some
some spacing and then make sure that
this text is lined up with at the very
least it should be its baseline should
be the bottom of this input or it should
be centered vertically let me check my
timer and check okay I think we're good
okay I'm gonna check I am gonna check
the chat now that we've I've showed you
both ways just suit you all think as
well
okay I don't see anything about that in
particular so I'm gonna go back to the
air and I did see a few more questions
in the chat so I'll get to those in a
few minutes let's yeah let's trim this
input down yes oh it can definitely be
trimmed down significantly yeah
so I believe we have some inline styles
on this input we can bring these down
too so let's switch this up and do
styles dot input and you can see I'm
trying to keep my Styles in the order
that things are on the page for now that
is helping me keep track of them may not
be like the best way of organization may
be better ways but it's working right
now
oops I don't need that okay there we are
it it usually makes sense to put your
Styles down below otherwise when you
start to get a lot up here it just it's
way too cluttered to have your styles in
line as well I mean I won't say never
put them in line but it's it's
definitely cleaner to put your Styles
down down below all right so on the
input let's give it a whiff we cut down
the height too you know what I do I
didn't want to leave it at 40 just so
it's a decent tap target for like on a
touchscreen but we can change
the width and want it to be pretty small
[Music]
let's go
80 let's see if if 80 works for this and
then for a text here for our math row we
could put justify content Center and
that should help us with our text there
okay so it made it a little bit better
it looks like
that's interesting it still didn't
exactly help us with our alignment for
our text so off to look into that
actually we could still go even smaller
with this input so let me try that I'm
gonna go with 60 see how that looks all
right that's more reasonable yeah 60
does seem a little more reasonable there
all right let's work out some of this
this padding right here in the inspector
so on our let's see what's going on here
this comes out as a div with just some
mm if we could do a line height whoa
that was crazy thought now I know why
that was crazy
there we go so if we change the line
height we can make this go up and down
right so we could do it like that
I mean I guess that works this doesn't
feel like the best solution but it'll
it'll work for now I could just try
let's just try increasing the font size
for now
I'm not I'm not like entirely opposed to
a larger font size you know this is a
like a kids game so like the larger font
is not like in terms of the genre of
like kids books and games and things
usually they go with a larger font
especially if they're just learning to
recognize their their numbers and things
it's easier if it's larger so let's go
with this size 26 font it looks like
it's fits well with this 40 pixel height
for the input so that that'll be a good
font size for us we'll go with that and
then let's add a little so we're going
to say padding let's go with our padding
left right sorry right let's go with
eight pixels there we go so that's face
out a little bit alright I think I think
that works so we're gonna bump this up
to 26 and then add padding rights of 8
pixels or 8 unitless numbers alright
that works that's cool we need some
space in between the submit button in
this row so we're going to go on the
container itself I don't want a huge
amount of space so I'm gonna try a
padding bottom of 8 and you'll see how
that looks all right great
all right not bad I mean I'm not this is
not gonna win any awards for design here
but like it's it's good enough that's
not gonna drive me crazy to look at okay
let's see know what else we can do
I mean I'm gonna probably change the
color of this button I kind of want to
leave the button really large too
especially when we consider the dis
running on a phone if if children are
going to be playing this game like their
dexterity you know with their fingers
probably not great so you want to make
sure tap targets are like probably
larger than we would even normally make
them okay all right this is not bad not
bad we got the basic UI I'm okay with
this for right now right I think on the
next stream I'd like to move on to some
of the logic of what's happening maybe
actually getting these to appear and
disappear depending on what's what's put
into here so yeah I'm okay for now so
I'm gonna go to the chat right now and I
know we I went a little over on the last
Pomodoro session I didn't notice when
this was actually the timer was up so
I'm gonna end this one a little early so
I have time for questions but definitely
want to commit this so that you all have
access to the code that we've done today
so let's do it get status and see okay
we modified app touch is great just like
we thought it's the only file we worked
in let's do a git commit and I'm gonna
give it an AM flag right which means
we're adding and we're committing and
we're gonna add a commit message to so
we're gonna say I like to kind of prefix
all of my commit messages so that we
kind of know what this is about so this
is a new feature right at the the
addition of
this UI elements feature we add UI for
characters all right so that's kind of
basic we did we did more than that but
essentially like what really what we
really added the biggest part we added
was we we have these these characters
now on the screen and so now we're gonna
push this up to get up if you're
wondering like how we set all this up we
did do some setup in the last stream and
then on my channel I go in-depth more
into like how to use get and set it up
on your computer so the the link to my
youtube channel is in the description if
if you you know need a little bit of
extra extra help like getting up to
speed on what we're doing here maybe
check out some of those tutorials and
that should should help you okay cool so
all that code should now be on github
let me show you the repo and so you can
go to it give it a refresh right so
here's our commit and I'm gonna put I
forgot to put this in the description to
the video so I'm gonna copy and paste it
right now in the chat this is the link
to the github repo I'll try to remember
to put it in the description for next
time okay so I'm going to do just a
little bit more question-and-answer
before we end this dream okay so Samuel
says I'm the newbie of a front-end
engineer what language do you recommend
except for JavaScript and PHP so you
want a language recommendation that's
not JavaScript or PHP and you're a
front-end engineer honestly like if
you're doing anything with front-end
like JavaScript is the language you need
to know that now if you want to pair
that with something backend and that's
not PHP
it kind of depends on what you want to
work on you you could go with you could
go with Java you could go with like
dotnet it just kind of depends on like
different factors like what you already
know what you're interested in if you
have a certain job you really want like
what does that company use you know
maybe you want to go with that so it's
it's hard to say but you know if you
want to focus on front-end you know
JavaScript really is necessary Costas
says hello is it worth learning Django
in 2019 thank you
all right so I would say if something is
worth learning it's just it is
definitely dependent on your situation
right I mean it's gotta be to be like
the same thing I just said if you know
the company you really want to work for
the technology you really want to work
with or whatever is is Django based then
it is worth it for you to learn it now
just if you are just getting into you
know software engineering or web
development and you want to know what to
learn I would not really even think of
Django as something to learn it to be
honest like I would say more focus on
JavaScript and you could run full-stack
JavaScript and I can see where that
takes you where you end up getting a job
what your clients need and and then kind
of decide like okay well all my clients
are using Django or my company is using
Django but I I wouldn't give the advice
to someone who's new to say like focus
on Django right now does that make sense
hopefully I answered your question
oh by the way Django is correct me if
I'm wrong but I believe Django is like
Python based am i right
see
John Hanson says the answers for so did
I defeat the enemy yes you that is the
correct answer
in MTS's how to create custom roms I
have no idea how to create custom ROM so
I'm sorry I don't really know about it
Habib says is the CSS coming from react
also yes so like this the stylesheet
object that that we have here this is
built into react native so this actually
does some cool optimizations with your
Styles so if you're using react native I
definitely recommend doing your Styles
like this it's not the only way but
because it's built in with I don't know
how it does it all in the background but
basically it will apply these Styles in
a way that's gonna be most helpful to
your performance alright so Peter asks
why are you using react native for
building a web UI is that a real
scenario actually yeah that's a really
good question because this concept of
using react native for the web instead
of using just regular react is a weird
concept right but the idea is if you use
react native to build a web app you can
use that same code base for your Android
and iOS app and then if you have a
desktop app as well the same code base
for that could be used right because you
could use something like electron to run
your your react native web app on the
desktop so the the idea is like you know
you have your your team or just you and
you don't have the resources to hire
people who are experts in iOS and
separate experts in Android and separate
experts in web so you want to be able to
share the code
and be able to do more with you know
your developers that you already have so
it is a real scenario so I'm actually
using react native web currently at my
job my normal job and the the idea
behind it is we want to be
cross-platform with one code base
Michael Krause has views and views and
views yeah actually it does
you definitely end up getting a lot of
views once we break these out into
components though it won't be all these
use together you know these will have
their own names as components so it will
it will look better like in terms of
what gets added to the Dom it's going to
be divs and divs and divs but at least
for the development of it it'll be a lot
cleaner
all right we had another question about
what am i building basically I'm
building a game a math game for children
to help them learn how to learn about
math
let's see I lost my place
okay so Michael then adds saying that
the point to build it like it's to build
it like this initially but also be
caught cross-platform so yeah that's a
good point Michael I forgot about that
too like it is the developer experience
for developing a web app is a lot better
than trying to develop on a mobile
device or even with an emulator so
building it like this actually is really
fast at least like for the basics and
then switch over to testing it on mobile
it's it's just a faster like the
feedback loop is faster it's it's easier
to figure out what the errors are so I I
definitely prefer this Peter says my
opinion is react plus material you I
would be more practical yes I'm assuming
you wrote that before my explanation so
I'm just I think my explanation kind of
deals with that although I definitely
love material UI and I really wish that
I could use material you I with react
native so I'm going to throw that out
there meteor UI is awesome
see
LaRose asks when the next stream is I'm
planning on Friday so hopefully
everything will go well on Friday
morning and I can get another stream in
so probably like 8 a.m. Eastern time
again Jarvis says love your work keep
going awesome thank you so much
touch this iya says what are these
clothes behind you oh this all right let
me let me show you what's behind me so
I'm currently in the corner of my
basement like right next to my washer
and dryer for clothes right so in order
to make this feel more like an office I
hung up table cloths from the ceiling to
give me like walls right so this has the
added benefit to is that when my kids
and stuff like pass through here like
they don't get in the view because I do
have I've had in the past
kids potty training and I apparently
have one kid potty training so they will
at times run through here naked on their
way to the bathroom so I can't have that
on YouTube so this is this was the
cheapest way for me to have some walls
up here so we're right now I'm in the
process of trying to buy a house another
house where I can then have a proper
office but for now this is like my
temporary solution I know it looks
really weird the people on my team make
fun of me and says it looks like I'm in
some type of dungeon or like fallout
shelter or something
yeah hello from Russia and Germany hey
how's it going
cool I might speak at a conference in
Russia I'm waiting to hear back to see
if I got selected so I'm excited about
about that and I was in Germany a couple
months ago I loved it
all right Ronald says can you tell me
what I can learn to be a front-end
developer and what kind of course or
path you recommend I definitely
recommend free code camp so check out
free code camp org and start through
their lessons and then they'll also have
a lot of links for extra information
that you can go out to but if you go
through the free code camp stuff you're
definitely gonna be on on the right
track MD X X demo
Hossein says subscribe thank you so much
Julio says did you consider flutter I
thought about flutter but I I'm I'm not
sure as far as I know flutter you can't
build a web app with flutter it's just
for mobile apps so correct me if I'm
wrong I probably still would have gone
with react native because it's been
around longer it has a larger community
there are more like large companies with
like apps in production you know they're
actually live so I feel better about
that but I think flutter is gonna be a
good option as it matures though Habib
says can't we use any front-end
framework with react I think that was in
response to like using material UI I
can't use material UI with react native
so it was built for react based on Dom
primitives so it you can't use it with
react native that has its own primitives
Geon says why do you have a computer
next to your washer because I have a
small house and it was the only place
that I could go that
wasn't already being used by my wife and
kids
dr. Hezekiah asked what software I use
for the video and screen capture OBS so
the software is called OBS it's free
it's cross-platform so check that out
Michael Creole says remember the
spaghetti of the last project yes it's
so glad that I'm not I don't have to do
anything more with that project like it
was I was proud of it
you know what we did with that last one
but it is kind of a relief to just be
able to move on tarcisius is hello from
Brazil since it's a really good Channel
oh thank you
Yogesh is hello from India also if I ate
mispronounced any of your names please
let me know because I'd love to be able
to pronounce them right so just let me
know how to pronounce them correctly
this shawl says what should I learn
react the react native if you want to do
mobile apps react native is the way to
go if you're just interested in web apps
then go with react although it's very
easy to switch between them like once
you learn one it's easy to learn the
other one because a lot of the concepts
are the same
okay so evidently you can create a web
flutter project now but it might be in
beta so alright thank you for that
cool off to check that out so I like I
said I think flutter potentially could
be really awesome but it's just it's too
new for me to be like comfortable and it
does make me nervous that as far as I
know Google is not really using it for
anything big yet so I I kind of worry
like that Google might not work on it
anymore so they do have the reputation
of like starting projects and then
abandoning them somewhat quickly so
whereas like Facebook and react like
very significant portions of Facebook
are built with react and react native
so it wouldn't they couldn't just drop
it right it would have to be a process
to rewrite parts of Facebook right so
there's a little bit more security built
in just because of how dependent
Facebook is on react at this point
Google is not at all dependent on
flutter at this point for very much of
anything so maybe that will change we
have ISO a a o Dell a a o Dell not sure
to pronounce that but says I'm
connecting all the way from Nigeria many
thanks for your videos I really
appreciate it can someone who is new
catch up with this tutorial you're
working on now oh yeah for sure we're
only on the third video so you could
definitely catch up not a problem if
you're watching the recordings I
definitely recommend watching him on to
time speed I talk slow enough that I
think that's doable and I sound way
smarter on too time speed because I
solve all the problems twice as fast
yeah but that'll help you get to room a
lot quicker since they are kind of like
an hour in length which actually I'm
gonna have to wrap this one up quickly
so let me get to these last few
questions
some Endre says hello from India every
time I watch your video and follow in
its again please say my name there we go
semaine de cemento
press wraps sing hello from Kim so rien
says hello from Cambodia can I start to
learn react native if I'm a beginner
definitely learn JavaScript like make
sure you know JavaScript know like your
basics of CSS so learn that first if you
already know some of that then yeah
going to react native but if you're like
totally new check out free code camp
Oregon go through there like HTML CSS
and like basic JavaScript stuff then
they'll they'll kind of ease you in to
react and then you should be ready for
react native
let's see
this is Mahesh says what is the minimum
requirement of react needed to get a job
I haven't started yet
it just entirely depends on the company
really you know maybe for like a junior
position you might only need like a year
of react native experience or whatever
like but I mean that if you pick it up
really fast and can build something
awesome with it you could probably
convince a company to hire you based on
your portfolio so it's it's really hard
to say vishal says what will be your
next video on react to react native my
next stream will be react native my next
video
I'm not sure I might do something with
graph QL in my next video actually so
well uh we'll see
Omar says hello is react native like
native script yeah it would be in the
same like category us as native script
for sure alright I gotta go and get to
my my real job it was so awesome being
able to start the day off with the live
stream with you all thank you so much
for watching for all your questions and
and your advice your help hopefully I'll
be back again on Friday morning oh it's
a Friday morning Eastern Time definitely
like check out I announced on Instagram
on Twitter before I do the stream so you
can follow me on there links to those
accounts are in the description check
out my youtube channel if if you're
interested if you liked what I did here
I have more like this on my youtube
channel and yeah have a great what day
is it Wednesday yeah have a great
Wednesday